التعايش يتطلب الكثير يحتاجون مكافحه تغير
المناخ وانقاذ الكوكب كان نسكن بجانب
بركان ونبني حصن يحمينا من حمامه او ان
نستفيد من انفجاره
سنعيدكم الى عام
1991 بركان جبلي بنابو في الفلبين يثور
من ثاني اكسيد الكبريت تطلق في طبقه
الاستراتوسفير في ينخفض متوسط درجات
الحراره العالميه بنحو درجه
الان البيت الابيض بصدده تنسيق خطه بحثيه
مدتها خمس سنوات وليس لتفجير البراكين بل
للمصادقه على مشروع مستوحى من انفجارها
برنامج يبرد الارض بمقدار درجه واحده
مئويه تكلفته اقل من عشره مليار دولار
سنويا
مقارنه بتقنيه التخطيط الاخرى
والتريليونات التي تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل
شركه
الشمس ستصنع غيوما عاكسه على ارتفاعات
عاليه قابله للتحلل للحيوي تبرد الكوكب
وتكبح والاحترام العالمي الكارثيه
العمليه اسمها تحسين البياض واصطلح العلمي
يشير الى عكس ضوء الشمس
للتساؤل نظريا
يرتدون ناجحا لكن كيف ستطبق عمليا من
بالونات نعم كما سمعتم بالبالونات
المصنوعه من ماده لاتكس سيتم اطلاقه ثلاثه
منها في الغلاف الجوي خلال يناير الحليب
نعم التجربه بدات ويعول على ان تنتج ما
يصل الى 500 جرام من ثاني اكسيد الكبريت
نجاح التجربه تعميمها بجهود عالميه سيخفض
درجه حراره الارض درجه واحده
من استخف بها كمبادله اداره المناخ في
كارنيجي ومن فكره جعل الغيوم اكثر بياضا
لكن الحلم في البيوت قد يتحقق وقد يمثل
الخطوه الاولى الحقيقيه في تكنولوجيا
انعكاس ضوء الشمس ونتائجها ستظهر قريبا
بالتاكيد صارت معكم عليها